[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce week-end ici à la fin de gagner on va
faire ce qu'on appelle la chasse aux
oeufs donc en fait on va accueillir les
familles qui vont venir les enfants ou
venir chercher les cons aura mis dans
l'est dans les prés au préalable et en
échange je sais cela du coup ils vont
ils vont pouvoir avoir des oeufs en
chocolat
[Musique]
la fête du jeu c'est vraiment pour
marquer le printemps et du coup au
printemps c'est un peu la renaissance il
ya des naissances du coup d'agneau de
chevreau des poussins des oiseaux voilà
les feuilles qui reviennent nous voir un
peu marquer le coup lors de cette fête
et c'est aussi l'occasion où on va
notamment tondre les moutons donc on va
récupérer la laine et du coup on va
faire des activités avec les enfants
autour notamment de la laine mais aussi
des nids de pour les oiseaux des choses
comme ça des petites plantations voilà
[Musique]
mais après deux ans de kovy doit chaque
fois on a préparé notre fête et au
dernier moment on n'a pas pu la faire on
était un peu frustré de pas la faire là
on est on est remonté à bloc pour
pouvoir accueillir tout le monde et on
est on est vraiment content de pouvoir
enfin la sphère du coup on est tellement
contents qu'on sait dire qu'on a à faire
sur deux jours et pas sur une journée
comme avant
une petite surprise que qu'on lâche
comme ça c'est que on a des petits
chamallows que les gens vont pouvoir
venir enrobées de chocolat on a une
petite fontaine en chocolat voilà c'est
la petite surprise
[Musique]